bonjour karim khelfaoui merci de
répondre à nos question selon vous cet
instrument provisoire qu'elle passe
sanitaire est ce qui doit être conservé
plus longtemps et si oui combien de
temps
la véritable question c'est est ce qu'il
aurait dû être mis en place dès le
départ on est face à une mesure qui n'a
absolument pas démontré l'efficacité qui
en réalité étaient là pour pousser les
gens à la vaccination mais qui a
finalement braquer une partie de la
population qui refuse de ma demande de
se vacciner qu'on aurait pu sans doute
avec le temps convaincre avec des
campagnes d'information basé sur la
raison et pas sur les émotions
défectueuse comme on le voit à la
télévision où on met en scène une
vieille dame qui va pouvoir tenir sa
petite fille si elle se fait vacciner
avec une injonction contradictoire à la
fin puisqu'elle est sans masque sans
rien et puis on lui dit pas respecté les
gestes barrière sas est un c'est un
mensonge on sait très bien que le fait
de se faire vacciner sa protégée des
chants bulgares mais on ne peut pas pour
autant tout arrêter lever les barrières
à venir c'est pas vrai hier le président
du medef geoffroy roux de bézieux a
demandé l'arrêt du pass sanitaires pour
les centres commerciaux alors que les
tribunaux administratifs sont de plus en
plus nombreux à suspendre la mesure dans
ces lieux votre point de vue
c'est à dire que là on est face à une
autre chaude égalité ne manifeste
atteinte à la liberté de se déplacer on
parle quand même aller faire ses courses
donc c'est la vie quotidienne qui
impacte t on prendre même pas le loisir
aujourd'hui la véritable question c'est
pourquoi est ce que ce gouvernement n'a
pas mis en place plutôt que des mesures
de contrainte liberticide des mesures
techniques et logistiques qu'il aurait
pu aider à limiter les contaminations je
pense par exemple à la les purificateurs
d'air on voit qu'il ya à peu près tout
le monde les installe et qu' il ya à new
york dans les pays à côté de mons est en
train d'être installés en france il ya
une fin de non recevoir de la part du
gouvernement on a un retard monstre sur
l'installation des capteurs de co2 il
n'y a aucune mesure qui a été prise pour
essayer de réguler les flux de
déplacement changer des horaires de
départ au travail etc pour aménager ces
flux et qu'on se retrouve pas à 200 dans
un bus donc voilà tout ça c'est des
mesures qui auraient pu être mises en
place qui ne l'ont pas été à la place
c'est une solution peu de stabilité avec
ces qr code et aujourd'hui on voit que
c'est très limité ils vont opérer
dispositif est ce qui se passe à chaque
fois pour l'état d'urgence on a
pérennisé pendant la loi organique pour
l'état d'urgence sanitaire il a été
renouvelé je ne sais pas combien de fois
quand l'ego quand l'assemblée nationale
de le suspendre et bien on refait voter
bah c'est bon on va pas s'en tirer si
demain il ya un huitième week end de
protestation
le mouvement anti passe sanitaire qu'est
ce que ça vous vous et voilà qui alors
que dans les manuels m'apprend à s'est
voulu évasif sur la prolongation ou non
hier de se passer ni terreau des adultes
du 15 novembre
est-ce que ça avait boxé quand on a un
mouvement contestataire qui est né dans
l'été ce qui est assez inédit ce qui
montre bien que là il ya un problème de
méthode clairement il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont dans ces manifestations et
qui ne sont pas des anti vaccins qui
sont vaccinées eux mêmes mais là il ya
un problème parce que en une fois de
plus on essaie de régler une crise
sanitaire par une atteinte aux libertés
sans développer les solutions annexes
par exemple celle que je faisais cité
tout à l'heure à côté de ça il n'y a pas
eu une seule mesure non plus pour
l'hôpital public on n'a pas vu
l'ouverture de lits ils ont continué à
en fermer on n'est pas sorti de la
logique libérale du flux tendu donc là à
l'hôpital public on sait qu'il ya une
deadline c'est le 15 septembre par
rapport à la vaccination obligatoire des
soignants est ce que vous voyez des
soignants même si vous êtes médecin
généraliste est ce que vous voyez à
l'hôpital d'aidés soignants commencé à
quitter le navire
moi j'ai des collègues des décollages
tout commence à monter des collectifs
notamment avec des armes et caetera et
qui pensent arrêter en fait ils veulent
pas continuer
l'habitat public il ya un philippe
martinez de secrétaire général de la cgt
hier il a dit que 6 5 à 10% du personnel
venait à quitter
l'hôpital en raison de l'obligation
faite au maximum ce serait une
catastrophe sanitaire
je suis absolument d'accord avec lui
c'est franchement je suis très inquiet
parce que l'hôpital était déjà dans un
sale état a vraiment à genoux et
s'adaptent pas dû qu'au vide chaque
année on est avec cette logique du flux
tendu avec un hôpital qui a du mal à
gérer simplement la grippe donc là vous
imaginez bien qu'avec le colis de ça a
été encore plus compliqué on a déjà vu
des départs qui ont fait que s'accentue
avec la crise qu vite parce qu on a
maltraité les gens parce qu'après on les
a insultés avec un ségur on leur a tendu
des cacahuètes et on leur a dit taisez
vous donc on est encore des départs
hélas si on a encore une vague de
départs c'est ça va être vraiment très
difficile le personnel est épuisé les
arrêts maladie se multiplient ceux qui
restent sur place bas ils sont encore
plus exploitée de manière extrêmement
extrêmement agressive extrêmement voilà
par la direction qui rappelle sur leurs
congés etc ont déclenché des plans
blancs plutôt que de rendre l'hôpital
attractif de de faire revenir des gens
et d'ouvrir des postes là ont déclenché
des plans blancs pour forcer ceux qui
sont pas en arrêt maladie à venir
travailler et ça ça va être très
compliqué parce qu'à un moment les gens
vont dire stop et si le jour où
l'hôpital public stefan quand on vous
dira que c'est vraiment une crise
sanitaire sans précédent qui va nous
arriver j'avais vu qu'il ségur
simplement rappel 1 183 euros nets
d'augmentation pour les soignants ce qui
avait été décidé mais une autre question
par rapport
ovarian muons c'est qu'elle le variant
delta qui pose beaucoup de soucis en ce
moment un peu partout dans le monde mais
il ya ce nouveau variant cette nouvelle
souche colombienne qui qui inquiètent
également est-ce que vous en avez vu est
ce que vous avez côtoyé des patients
atteints de cette souche est est ce que
vous êtes inquiet par rapport à ce
nouveau variant
alors j'ai pas encore vu de patients
atteints de cette souche après elle pour
l'instant très peu diffusée mais c'est
vrai que c'est une des variantes qui est
sur la liste de surveillance de l'om est
ce notamment parce que la vaccination et
mon efficacité avec cela rien à mettre
au conditionnel parce que ça on va avoir
besoin de plus d'études mais surtout ce
que ça nous montre c'est que en réalité
la stratégie vaccinale qui a été
employée elle n'a absolument aucun sens
au niveau national elle a un sens si
elle est déployée au niveau mondial tant
que vous aurez des pays et pas loin de
la moitié de la planète qui n'a pas
accès aux vaccins ou qui est très peu
accès aux vaccins vous allez avoir un
virus qui va continuer à circuler donc
il va continuer à muter il va y avoir de
nouveaux variants et à un moment ou à un
autre il va alors forcément des
mutations qui vont permettre à ces
nouveaux variantes de passer mieux dans
la population vaccinée ou le vaccin sera
un peu moins efficace etc et ça ça va
lui donner un avantage sélectif donc on
risque de le voir se généraliser on a un
vrai problème de stratégie merci karl
khalfaoui d'avoir répondu à la question
je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste